[موسيقى]
بطل خارق ومبرمج خطير ينقذ البشر من حرب
قادمه ثم قاتل ماجور وغيرها ادوار جعلت
كيانو ريفز احد الفنانين الاكثر جماهيريه
ودفعته لتخطي ازمات كبرى في حياته الشخصيه
والحفاظ على جماهريته كنجم استثنائي في
سماء هوليود فما قصته ولد كيانو تشارلز
عام
1964 في لبنان لابن من هاواي وام من
انجليزيه عملت فنانه ومصممه ازياء لكن
والده عانى من تعاطي المخدرات وسجن بتهمه
بيع الهيروين كان حينها في الثالثه فقط من
عمره فبقي مع والدته وشقيقته حيث انتقلت
العائله الى سدني ثم الى مدينه نيويورك
قبل ان تستقر في تورنتو تزوجت والدته ثلاث
مرات اخرى بعد ذلك ف كانت طفولته غير
مستقره عاطفيا كذلك لم يبدي ريفز اهتماما
بالدراسه بقدر الانشطه الترفيهيه التي
قادته للمشاركه بعمل فني من انتاج فرقه
الروك الامريكيه دام يانكيز عندما كان في
التاسعه
اهتم ريفز بالفن فعلا وحصل على قبول في
مدرسه ايتوبيكو للفنون المسرحيه حيث شعر
بانه ينتمي لهذا العالم لكن الفرحه لم
تكتمل حيث تم طرده بسبب سلوكه المتمرد
وانتقل لمدرسه ديلاسال حيث احب الرياضه
الهوكي وتميز فيها كحارس مرمى لفريق
المدرسه اطلق عليه حينها لقب the wal لكن
الامر لم يكتمل ايضا بسبب تعرضه لاصابه
بعد ذلك قرر ريفز التركيز على المسار
الفني وظهر في اعمال مسرحيه وفنيه منخفضه
التكاليف لكن اول ظهور احترافي له كان في
حلقه من المسلسل الكوميدي
في عام
1984 وبعد عامين
ظهر في فيلم الذي تدور احداثه حول رياضه
الهاكي في كندا
بعد فتره وجيزه سافر ريفز الى هوليود حيث
شارك بمجموعه متنوعه من الافلام كان من
اهمها
الذي حصل من خلاله على اول ترشيح لجائزه
الاوسكار
مع بدايه تسعينيات القرن الماضي تلقى صدمه
كبرى في حياته عندما توفي صديقه المقرب
ريفر فينكس بجرعه زائده من المخدرات لكنه
واصل المسيره وقام بمجموعه من الاعمال
المهمه مثل فيلم سبيد الذي نال بفضله
جائزه ام تي في لافضل ثنائي مع ساندرا
بولوك وهي الجائزه التي احرزها مره اخرى
بالمشاركه مع لورنس فيشبرن في عام
1999 عن ثلاثيه
التي جعلته نجما كبيرا على الشاشه كما
اظهرت جوانب اخرى من شخصيته وهو يتنازل عن
معظم ارباحه لفريق المؤثرات الخاصه ومصمم
الازياء لانه شعر بانهم الابطال الحقيقيون
للفيلم
بعد ثلاثيه
واثر مروره بالعديد من المشكلات كوفات
ابنته عام
1999 ووفاه والدتها جنيفر بعد عامين في
حادث سياره خفت نجم ريفز لسنوات ورغم انه
ظهر في عده افلام لاحقه وقام لاول مره
بالاخراج في فيلم
الا انه لم ينل الاستحسان الذي اعتاده حتى
عام 2014 عندما بدا الظهور بدور قاتل
ماجور في سلسله جون ويك التي ابقته في
فضاء النجوميه حتى يومنا هذا
رغم نجاحاته وتحقيقه ثروه تقدر بنحو 380
مليون دولار بقي ريفز منعزلا لفترات طويله
عن المحيط الخارجي والاعلام فيما القى
الحزن بظلاله دائما على ملامحه ما جعله
يلقب بممثل هوليود الانطوائي
[موسيقى]